this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by nobody because every
little thing you think that's me every
little thing you thing that me every
little thing that's just feeding your
greed or a bear that you were fine
without him
[Music]
hello Madison I'm not always in a
wheelchair but we were driving from
Chicago up here and right around the
Illinois border just passing the
Illinois border we stopped to get gas
and Josh got into a knife fight with an
11 year old he was so mean no I opened
my car door bottle fell out it fell on
the ground I have no idea how this
happened but it just shattered and it
bounced up and Ryan looks over and he
goes are you okay I said I don't know
and I looked over and I haven't seen
this much blood in real life ever this
was about four hours ago
[Applause]
and so I go running it's one of those
loves the gas stations right super clean
sanitary bathrooms and I go running in
there and there's like it's just blood
all over my boot I used to have another
boot that looked like this one and now
it's red I was blood all over my sock it
somehow cut through my pants cut through
my sock and then through my leg and yeah
I go into the bathroom and thank God my
my partner Rebecca is she was there and
she has all kinds of first-aid training
and she just started like doing some
ninjutsu and there was just blood
everywhere
ryan walks into the bathroom and the
first thing I hear is oh my god am i
right
there I mean when I say there was blood
everywhere like there was blood
everywhere all over the bathroom but
thank God there were two nurses who just
happened to be there and they sold Josh
bleeding and they were like oh we can
help they have the husband and wife
couple and they came in and they were
helping back stitch up my leg well while
Ryan was running around urinals
panicking well Joshua so calm like
someone that is handing but you know
we're not going to let that just a
little blood
stop us from being here tonight
[Applause]
hey y'all let's record a podcast well
hello everybody my name is Joshua fields
Millburn and i am ryan nicodemus and
together we are the minimalist welcome
to a live version of our podcast in
Madison Wisconsin hello Madison
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you you know
usually we take phone calls but if you
got out your phone right now and call
this up it'd be a little strange thank
you so we have a microphone around here
somewhere I'm pretty sure and if you
want to walk up to the front Sean where
is the microphone over here but is the
stage left a house right if I'm correct
so if you want to walk up here and start
with questions we will start with some
long-winded answers you can ask a
regular question and we'll maunder on so
we come toward some sort of date on with
your question and and then we'll move on
to a lightning round I usually Ryan and
I have a long time to think it just
ruminate over we're going to respond
because our lightning round we try to
respond with less than 140 characters to
people but since we have 7 seconds
instead of 7 days we've turned it into a
rap battle without rapping I think
you'll see what I mean in a few moments
but before we before we dive in we up
here with a microphone somewhere sure ok
cool cool it's right up here on my left
your right
unless you're facing the same way I am
thank goodness are you ready yeah are
you ready yes beautiful
welcome Hey thank you what's your name
where are you from
and then what's your question hopefully
in that order um I'm Liz and I live in
Madison Wisconsin bulges are right now
and I do have a question me my roommate
we're going to be moving in June and
we're really excited and we I have been
listening to your podcast she has not
and I'm just wondering if you have any
suggestions on our move we do have a
minimalist packing party that we are
going to be doing with us and our cast
our cats will not be participating but
we plan on we're moving into a place
that's a lot smaller than our place
right now but we want to hear about tips
and I want you to give her some tips so
that'd be great thank you a few
questions for you don't go don't only
the microphone yes you're not off the
hook so where are you moving in town
yeah we're moving into Madison and we're
moving from a Madison apartment to
another Madison apartment but smaller
than it's about five hundred square feet
smaller than our current place and you
have two roommates now so it's you and
now there's you and one of the relators
two people together change ball tariqat
okay I love that sitcom
[Music]
the one with Charlie Sheen right yeah I
think that's someone okay um anyway so
so you're moving to a smaller place and
and in that smaller place you are hoping
to have fewer things than you currently
have is that correct of course and we
already did the minimalist challenge
where we got rid of one item each day
like two one item you talk about the
30-day minimalism games you partner up
with yeah there's someone who played it
and won it sounds like everybody wins
the 30-day minimalism game unless you
lose the way it works you partner up
with someone beginning a month you each
get rid of one item on the first day
it's friendly competition we all know
decluttering is boring as well and so we
found a way to make a little more more
fun with some friendly competition first
day them onto each get rid of one item
second day the month two items so it
starts off really easy to give you that
momentum you need by the middle of the
month
it gets much more difficult right by day
15 it's like what 15 items I'm not going
to get rid of today day 20 what 20 items
am I going to get rid of today because
tomorrow I have to go out of 21 items
and so the minimalism game is a way to
give you that momentum whoever goes the
longest between the two of you wins and
if you both make it to the end of the
month you've both won because you've
made it 496 items total at a 30 day
minimalist that's correct
now our minimalist family did this a few
months ago we modified the rules I don't
we don't own more than 496 items I don't
think but Ella does and she's three and
so we just got rid of her stuff and it
was so easy
no I you can modify the rules however
you want so let me ask you this why why
do you want why do you want to give why
do you want to get to have fewer things
in this new space you persuade not not
not your roommate but why do you
personally I personally like to have
less things I what I guess it's just
makes things more tidy yes and a decree
pleasing yes and every place has a place
in your apartment so like if it's a
coffeemaker
you know where it goes it's a I think
everyone here knows where their coffee
maker goes I hope it's just everything
everything has a place in your in your
apartment so you're not shoving things
like we have a cupboard full of
Tupperware yeah is like you open it
things fall out of this you got a
Tupperware party it'd be great to have
but of course we need to beware to pack
our lunches to make our our week go by
our week to go by nicer because we prep
our foods we take a lunch to work things
like that so things that we need but at
the same time we want to not have a lot
of stuff what about your roommates is
she does she want as I'm saying she I
was amazing she yes okay okay yes I like
kitchen things because I like to cook
but she has one fewer kitchen items and
and and why does your roommate for from
your words
want to have fewer things well the way
that we we think differently is a thing
like she sees things as a collection
like if she bought things together it
would it's like yeah it's an OCD thing
it's an LCD so she wants collections of
things like say that you have well I get
it so like if you have you have a
collection of things you can count as
one thing and that's fewer things right
no okay we have an absolute so you have
right well look we'll stick it to the
microphone cuz people home can't hear
you shouting although I appreciate it so
so just a tangent on collections you're
collecting is well-planned hoarding
right I mean we all realize this it's
just I guess some hordes are more
appropriate than others right across the
street from me I there's a hoarders
house and like there is like there
aren't they don't have curtains because
they have boxes of stuff stacked all the
way up you can't see into the house and
I suppose that's that's the unhealthy
kind of collecting there are some other
collections that are much healthier than
that anyway I hope that answers your
question
no I so let me let me let me answer your
question we now now you're at the
perfect time to access your stuff this
is the time where you're literally
forced to deal with every single thing
that you own
that's why Ryan did his packing party
because he knew like I'm not moving
right now but the times when I have
moved I had to deal with things and oh
by the way when I went over to help him
with the packing party he saw boxes in
his garage from the last time he had
moved it still hadn't been open and most
of you have experienced that as well and
then be in your garage there are clothes
or attic or somewhere else
but there are so many things that we
move from place to place to place
what's the old George Carlin joke he
said our houses
just like graveyards for our stuff and
it kind of feels that way and and so now
is the time where you are forced to to
come to terms with the things you have
in your life and you're going out you're
going to want to start asking that
question does this add value to my life
and you have to be honest with yourself
and if the answer is no or I don't think
so and let it go it's okay and it
implements some rules in your life going
forward because getting rid of the
clutter is the first step but then we
want to be careful not to bring clutter
back in so ask that same question we're
bringing new things into our lives it's
equally as important because otherwise a
year from now you'll be asking the same
questions yeah I'd love to hear that you
guys are doing the you guys are doing
the packing parties I hear that
correctly yeah I mean it might be
different from yours because we're gonna
we're gonna pack things and then we're
gonna unpack them we're not gonna wait
two weeks
oh yeah do that that's cool I'm where I
want why can't you
Oh week I have a cat that pees on things
when nobody knows in this room I can't
wait around to unpacking no no but he
didn't he he unpacked only my pannikin
unit over three weeks so on that first
day you literally unpacked everything
you need you need a litter box you
unpack it you need a toothbrush you
unpack it right yeah you did you did
we went little for the cat right yes no
no it's funny because I had like a mound
of toys for my cat and I remember like I
just like got one of the whatever boy I
had some kind of squishy ball thing that
he he was an awesome cat like played
fetch it was great and it was like the
ball that we always play fetch with and
I was like all right like I'll sit there
and play fetch with you and you know
what leg
he he was he didn't feel deprived of all
the other toys still had a blast I mean
you can you can take whatever approach
you want you know um Josh and I are here
to just you know share our recipe and if
there are ingredients that work for you
to make your own recipe great but I
don't think anyone could totally mimic
my packing party or you know Josh's
paring down over months um so you guys
are the packing party that's awesome I
guess if you're going to take the
approach where you're going to pack
unpack stuff right away um I gotta tell
you it's not much of a packing party no
offense but but however you whatever
your approach is I would just echo what
Josh said about the rules set some
guidelines for yourself before you start
unpacking everything into your new home
because I'll tell you like when Josh
came over and it was time to start
sorting stuff in to donate sell recycle
uh I was like going through every item
and I had that just in case syndrome
where I like you know forty coffee cups
and I'm like you know well it's 39 of
them break I've got another one and I
remember like you know I'm like going
through this stuff in my head and like
trying to talk myself into hanging on to
all these little things and Josh he had
a 50 gallon trash bag and he was just
like sweeping stuff into it like it's so
much easier to get rid of other people's
stuff
so you can have some fun knowing that if
you're helping each other out so as Josh
a sweeping stuff in the bag I'm like
dude what are you doing man like I got
go through that stuff like I just don't
want to like just you know sweep stuff
into the back and he's like what he's
like what about this this mug right here
says world's number-one granddad on it
like when do you ever going to use that
and you know my well you know I mean I
haven't really used it I don't know
where the heck I got it
but you know like I don't know if I'm
going to use it but I again I drink
coffee and in case 39 cups of my 40 cups
break then you know I've got that I'll
be by like my you know my back up to my
back up to my back up to my back up
anyway so Josh was like when's the last
time you use that and I'm like I've
never used that cup and it kind of made
me instill this this is like the first
rule I ever took on it was if I hadn't
used it in the last year and I didn't
plan on using it within the next year
like I felt pretty good about getting
rid of that just in case item so I took
that approach with all of that stuff
that I attacked up I think now it's more
like 90 days on either side there are
some exceptions to the rule like my
snowboard I'm not going to snowboard in
May or you know you might have snowing a
murder Hannah right now you used to be
able to snowboard in November in Montana
but not anymore but anyway I mean there
are exceptions to that rule but having
rules like that that's really what's
going to help you determine what is the
most important things that you need in
your new apartment and it's a
just-in-case rule like that has been a
lifesaver for Josh and I where you can
replace anything that you're holding on
to just in case if you haven't used it
in the last year and you're not going to
use it within the next year you could
probably get rid of it and if it ever
comes up again we're like oh shoot like
I should have held on to that HDMI cable
that
I was it that was sitting in my junk
drawer but you can I guarantee you
within less than twenty minutes and for
less than $20 and go replace an HDMI
cable and that rule it sounds at first
like oh well I just don't want to I
don't want to have to like go and spend
twenty dollars every single day when I
need something if that's how it worked
we want to suggest that that's silly
[Music]
Josh and I we have been implementing
that rule for the last four years five
years now five years yeah and we've used
it I can count on one hand combined how
many times we've used that and like I'll
give you one example it was really silly
like I used to always have a toothbrush
in my travel bag it was like an extra
toothbrush but now he doesn't travel
with a toothbrush right now no brush my
teeth minimalism and I had it there just
in case like well what if something
happens like what if I lose that
toothbrush I packed with me or you know
it falls in the toilet and I have to you
know I got that backup toothbrush and I
got rid of it a couple years later like
you know it turned out that like I
forgot to bring my toothbrush with me
and there was this moment of like oh man
I usually have an extra toothbrush in my
bag but I don't even think I'd spend
actually it was a free toothbrush I got
from the lobby like downstairs in the
hotel so it wasn't even twenty minutes
and it didn't cost me anything but it's
it's uh it's a very freeing thing when
you can come up with things like rules
like that where you feel confident with
and you can let stuff go and know that
yeah like you're not going to be able to
prepare for every situation but if you
have some very specific rules in your
life like you can prepare for most
situations without hoarding a bunch of
stuff thank you thank you
[Applause]
all right let's do at least one more
long-winded answer and then we'll see
where we are before I move on to the
lightning round all right
Stephanie from Milwaukee Wisconsin so
nice it's not just me I'm glad you're
still coming to Wisconsin and just our
Milwaukee in December there's no better
time to go to Milwaukee than December
right so you guys are minimalist but you
definitely bring maximum hustle and so
my question is you have all of the work
that comes with being the minimalists
right but then in the past couple of
years you've launched asymmetrical press
you've launched landed coffee among
writing books and doing documentaries
and so my question is first what drives
you to achieve all of these different
things and then I guess beyond that how
are you spinning up all of these
different side hustles without also
spinning up maximum mental flutter solid
state question
you know I'll say like when you call
yourselves with the minimalists
everything becomes ironic I mean there's
not a very minimal amount of people here
tonight no you know at the end of the
day Josh and I I know it seems like
we're really really busy and you know if
Josh and I would have started this whole
thing with if I went to him after that
packing party and said dude we could
start a blog we can write three books we
could start a documentary we could start
a publishing company I can started
mentoring business you can start a
writing class we could go on tour I mean
if that's how we would have started but
first we have to solder coffee shop
right but first affix our coffee shop we
would have gotten nowhere and and what
Josh and I have done over the last six
years is very deliberately have chosen
the things that we want to focus on so
for all those things that you just
mentioned there are dozens of other
things
I dare say like hundreds of other things
we've said no to in order to say yes to
the coffee shop in order to say yes to a
symmetrical press in order to say yes to
the store that were on this year you
know I would love to sit here and say
that Chuck Josh and I we have this
secret formula with the stickit formula
formula to do all these things just by
ourselves and if you buy all three of
our books you'll have all the answers I
mean it just doesn't work right I
imagine you stand in front of a
chalkboard with like the quadratic
formula behind you I think it works that
way though yeah they don't have the
formula no it doesn't but what I'll say
is that when it comes to asymmetrical
breasts I mean we're not in that by
ourselves that is that is a press that
we started with Colin right he came to
us in 2012 and he had like this really
weird Venn diagram business plan drawn
up that I really didn't understand but
as you talked me through it I started to
understand more and more and there are
tools out there that we use that you
know we don't have to have like a
warehouse full of books
we had friends who were already writing
that we wanted to kind of coach through
the the publishing process and yeah it's
a it's a great adventure that we've been
on but at the end of the day I mean
we've got five authors six hunters it's
six yeah I can't look you can count
Collin Collin three or four times right
he's 32 years old has written 36 books
yeah but you know we don't have like
this big publishing warehouse I mean
it's kind of a side hustle or a side
project or a side passion that you can
kind of look at it that way when it
comes to the coffee shop we have some
amazing partners who we met that because
they they took some photos of us and we
were just having a conversation about
you know what they wanted to do and they
were talking about how they were just in
their current roles and they wanted to
get out and they do they did photography
on the side that was their side house
when they're like eventually we're gonna
open up open up a coffee shop and all
the cards just kind of fell in place to
where Josh and I were able to contribute
and partner with those guys in st.
Petersburg to to open up that coffee
shop but I guess to make this long
answer short Josh and I we pick one
thing a year to focus on and you know
this year it's this tour last year it
was you know spreading our work our
message our story with with the
documentary in 2014 it was a hundred
city tour in 2015 we donated so much of
our time to building schools and wells
and and and other things but because we
can say no to so many other things like
we can say yes to these to these side
hustles I guess and at the end of the
day I have like I have a friend who she
she's a writer she's an artist she's an
actress she really loves to do all these
things and you know I
like Ryan show me how to like make money
off my passion and I'm like it doesn't
really work that way like the biggest
piece of advice I could give to her was
you pick one thing like you put
everything into it and if you can add
value that people love your work like
you're gonna figure out a way to make
ends meet
she's like I knew you were going to say
that I can't just pick one thing and I'm
like okay that's fine but you know she
has has this um you know a starving
artist lifestyle that is very it works
for her well um but she she knows that
she's choosing to kind of do everything
at once if Josh and I try to do
everything and once like I said it would
not have worked like what we've done
over the last six years is built up
these layers I guess and I wish I could
say that like Josh and I are just
hustling like crazy and and that's how
him and I make it work but we have so
many people around us that help us make
everything work yeah I would just add to
that real quick yeah you actually drives
us it's our values that drive us and
we're really clear on what our values
are and so on top of that the other
thing that drives us is we make sure
that any of the decisions we make that
the financial side of things is never
the primary driver and I say primary
very specifically it's going to always
be a part of the equation if you're
doing some sort of business because you
can't just constantly lose money on a
business and and call that a business
plan it's not that's an expensive hobby
and but it's never the primary question
it eventually it becomes part of the
equation at some point and in some
things we will lose money that that tore
the Ryan talks about in 2014 we lost
money on that tour we lost a significant
amount of money and we learned a lot
from that process we we did a hundred
well actually 100 cities 119 events
they're all free and we had to rent out
some spaces by the end of it because the
the message was spreading so much and so
many of the spaces you see in the
documentary were just places we had to
rent out with out of our own pocket
and and that is an equation for failure
if you do that into perpetuity and so
what we learned is then we next time we
do a tour how do we at least break even
and in doing so contribute along the way
so on this tour Ryan and I don't really
make any money we'll be lucky to break
even and I think we will but what I have
learned is that we can surround those
the third thing we surround ourselves
with very capable people so we have
Shawn Harding who was called podcast
Shawn on the podcast he's back here
somewhere ladies and gentleman podcast
Sean and Sean is really the man behind
the minimalism he makes everything that
we do sound more polished and he does a
lot of our work he's our tour manager
while we're on the road and just an
all-around outstanding guy and it would
be nearly impossible to this lousy Sean
so really appreciate you brother thank
you so much and we also have Jessica
Williams around here somewhere
she handles all she's way back there in
the back and she'll be at the the
merchants yeah hey Jess she'll be as the
the merch booth afterward I'm pretty
sure my leg will heal up to each of you
by at least two books
oh no I'm kidding in fact when we leave
here tonight when you leave here tonight
if you're welcome to pick up a book if
you do please minimize it afterward find
out someone else who donated to either a
library friend family member enemy any
anyone you want to give the book to and
if you can't afford a book I would you
just forgot your wallet that's fine and
come up afterward and we'll it's all not
so let us buy you a copy of the book as
long as you're willing to pass it on
after the fact and and so Jess will be
out there she also helps us out with our
social media and so the reason that all
of our social media looks so curated and
beautiful is she does an outstanding job
with that she also helps out with our
minimalist org we have a hundred free
local meetup groups including in
medicine and so there are our free local
meetup groups where people would come up
to us after the after our tour stops and
they'll say hey how do I connect with
open-minded people locally note saddle
no but good luck and then we leave town
and we'd be gone and so what we did is
we left behind these free local meetup
groups in 100 cities so you could once
you're gone you there's a bunch of not
like-minded people here but open-minded
people you probably have different
beliefs the people in this room have
different beliefs but you have similar
values and so my values drive me
Ryan's values Drive him and even though
we have different beliefs that's okay at
a secret we voted for two different
people in the last election oh my god
how could you be best friends with
someone who didn't vote for the same
person as you or how about this we have
different religious beliefs we have
different personalities he's an
extrovert I'm an introvert he's really
in the moment like then in the moment
and I've planned everything out six
months in advance and that's okay
because those beliefs they get us to the
same values we just take different paths
to get there so that's what drives me I
surround myself with with great people
make sure they're adequately compensated
because I don't I don't need much as
long as I can provide for my family I
feel great about that
so I don't put the money first but it
will be part of the equation thank you
so much you want to give
I look through one more long-winded and
then we'll hop into the lightning round
what's your name my name is Amy from
Madison and I have a feeling my question
might be good for the lightning round
perfect ladies and gentlemen it is Ron
with Brian what time is it it is time
for our hashtag ask the minimalist
lightning round where we are on Twitter
and Instagram and Facebook right Jeff
Facebook yeah okay at the minimalist and
usually you can like tweet your
questions to us and we try to answer it
during our lightning round and like this
pit the less than 140 character response
and Ron and I will pour over this for
days and like how can I make this even
shorter and more like effective but now
we're going to battle it out and you are
the judge and so we'll try to monitor on
a bit until we get down to some
concision that we can make tweetable
you all can share it as well if you like
you can share it on social media in fact
if you share any photos or anything from
the night if you use hashtag less is now
because that's the name of the tour less
is now we will repost some of our
favorite images and tweets and all that
other fun stuff Amy what's your question
it's about something that's very very
dear to my heart gala Ambrosius
chocolates is right across the street
theoretically how vast of the chocolate
collection would a minimalist have man
we're going to call to audibles in a row
with you I think I love chocolate our I
don't know where David is but Live
Nation is the promoter for the tour this
is our eighth tour in seven years and
it's our first proper tour though and so
we actually have like a tour promoter
and David is here from Live Nation he
bought me a bag of chocolates from the
place across the street and I have not
eaten them yet because I'm going to eat
a chocolate right now and how about Sky
Steel who opened up for us tonight how
awesome was that
[Applause]
so sky is a musician obviously and you
know how musicians used to put out like
cassette singles back in the day
where's a college town they may not
remember the contestant yeah it's that
yeah cuz that they put out a single and
like you would have this whole like it's
almost a sensory experience not just the
I mean a multi-sensory experience it
wasn't just I'm going to listen to this
music which is beautiful but I'm going
to unwrap this cassette and then I'm
going to open it up I'm going to read
the liner notes and the dedications and
the acknowledgments and who wrote the
song and that was awesome but we don't
have that anymore because we have
Spotify or whatever and I'm grateful for
that now I no longer have to own 2,000
CDs that are alphabetized on my wall I'm
the one with OCD out of the pair anyway
I don't have to own those CDs anymore
because they're right there at my
fingertips but I still like have any
sensory experiences with with my music
and so Skye said instead of just selling
a single with an on a cassette or a disc
or whatever how about I create an
experience for our music so he found the
perfect chocolate to pair his single
with it's of a company called Vosges
chocolate there they're out of Chicago
and they made a chocolate specifically
for his single and so maybe we could ask
a guy to come out here and play that
single and maybe Ryan and I will eat
some chocolate in front of you oh man
ladies and gentlemen Scottsdale
[Applause]
can I get a short hug thanks brother you
know I just want I just realized that
there is like blood all over my pants
[Music]
Wow okay I got it I got it ladies and
gentlemen I just want to brag for a
second on the sky this is um Vanessa
Carlton's violinist design has anyone
heard of Vanessa Carlton yeah
we are so lucky to have him with us we
don't eat both of them again again thank
you can you tell us about this yeah so
you dislike okay go for it go for it so
my friend Katrina her whole thing with
chocolate is telling stories so I fed
her the song I said can you tell this
story in chocolate and you know
chocolate traditionally used how I was
used ceremonially by a lot of indigenous
cultures is sort of a heart-opening
substance so the song is a love song for
the earth and she put some flavors in
there that she thought would sort of
bring you take you on that experience
and heighten the experience of
connecting to the earth to connecting to
the natural world so we're going to let
you guys what's in the chocolate the
chocolate it's gotten and did we bring
it up for everyone it I brought enough
for everyone and everything in the
chocolate is legal in some some places
no it's all legal everywhere wait you
don't have found out last night did you
eat it no it's right here well you don't
I thought that last night what guy has
not tried one of the chocolates yet
because you've always planned today so I
know I'm like a new hopper and I was
like why don't you give me your violin
I'll play the song are you ready I'm
ready
all right Ryan Cheers all right now take
your time you got to make the chocolate
laughs yeah it's part of the thing all
right okay let's let them be a little we
don't want them to have to eat in front
all these peoples who put them in the
dark a little bit in the side of the
mountain come to me come to me like a
dream and I know our home to me comes to
me
[Music]
yeah yeah oh my god so Scott good but
let's do one more chocolate and one more
song took a box the pairs with the album
or something okay so so this guy has
will have these afterward after the fact
out there he's selling his new single
and you can eat it so I that's my short
answer to your question I had something
to do with chocolate I think I think two
is apparently the appropriate amount yes
it's a shared experience all right let's
move on the rest of the lightning round
wait we had that sir a question about
chocolate what about that didn't answer
her question well no it was how much
chocolate how Miami let's have two
pieces okay gotcha how many songs do I
have to play oh man um alright well I
guess that was those the answers no I I
was thinking of a tweetable answer I'm
just going to warm up for the lightning
round I was going to eat a link to that
song yeah um you know it doesn't matter
how much chocolate you eat what does it
matter how much chocolate you eat if you
have a void chocolate is probably the
last thing that's going to fill that
void what solid ryan nicodemus for the
win on that one
[Music]
they come how about did I try to steal
on this food is not entertainment but
that sure was good
make sure your question thank you very
much hi guys how's it going
hey what's your name I'm Kate I'm from
Madison sweet so my question is I'll
make it very quick what if you have a
partner who has no interest in becoming
a minimalist but you do but you do I
mean I do are you having I want to we
live together and he has no interest in
it
why stubbornness probably it's
interesting so how might his lights be
better with less I can think about how
much my life would be better with less
of his stuff but you know it isn't it
isn't it funny and and I I totally get
where you're coming from
it isn't it funny though how we get into
a spot where everything happens to us
it's hard it's hard to like I mean if I
was watching TV it's like my screen or
my phone or it's my things and and it's
hard for us to step into the the the
other person's shoes so when I say how
might his life do but you know how your
life would be better with less right I
mean and the reason I ask how would his
life be better with less then we start
to think like well I know how mine would
be and so I mean my mind Act my actual
short answer to your question is how
might his life be better with less and
if you can answer that and you can
answer it adequately anyone can be
inspired to let go of what super fullest
thank you
[Music]
um yeah I wish like there was this magic
answer to say like oh this is how you
have your partner become a minimalist
like this is the this is the way to do
it um you know at the end of the day
like that just it's not how it works
it's it's a long process in fact Josh
would have come to me and said hey man I
found this thing called minimalism he
needs like it because you got a lot of
[ __ ] I prefer to just let that have been
like what person would have felt judged
and then I would have projected that
judgment and it would have been like oh
yeah whatever screw you like I don't
need I don't need that but seeing the
benefits is will really maybe go to him
and ask him that question
um what I'll say you know Mariah she's
not a minimalist I mean she has pared
down her things significantly since we
met but like I never asked her to do any
of that uh what I'll say is that Mariah
and I we have very similar values very
similar beliefs and we go out of our way
to support each other so I think my
short answer would be in order to have
meaningful relationships you must
support those people but it's impossible
to support someone if they don't support
you back I think I pulled that one out
we tied it up nicodemus are we tied up
that means it's time to go into a
tiebreaker question what uh who do we
have up here hey my name is Richard I'm
from Madison first off a shout out to my
girlfriend we had a big date night
planned tonight but I forgot I ordered
tickets months ago so we had to cancel I
love you honey bunny
wherever you are
so start off with that I'm sure she
appreciates that so about a year ago
I worked at a gas station living check
to check I was drinking every day I was
out of shape I was living with my
friend's mama jenever car and then over
the past year I got a really good job
with no health care moved up to Madison
cleaned myself up and got a car and I
kind of developed this weird neurotic
Drive for setting goals and achieving
them because you get that euphoria from
it I don't necessarily have like a
materialistic kind of like hoarding but
I often like hoard goals where it's like
you know I've achieved so much so quick
and I want to keep doing it but like I
never find myself happy because like you
know I achieve this this and that but I
always have you know those other goals
so I guess my question is how do you
like minim minimalize the mental clutter
or like the mental like goals or dreams
that that you have to deal with that
yeah I think it's an important question
so I'll tell you a few years ago back
2011-2012 I got rid of all my goals I
let go of goals now in the corporate
world I used to be the goal guy I had
spreadsheets of goals I had career goals
I had financial goals I had personal
goals at vacation goals I had consumer
purchasing goals goals goals goals and I
was pretty good achieving a lot of them
of the youngest director of my company's
140 year history at age 27 of
responsible for 150 retail stores and I
got there and it was like wait I am NOT
winning I received the goal but I was
always looking over the shoulder of the
present moment
figuring out what the next goal was
going to be and it stressed me the hell
out and so I decided to get rid of my
goals for I end up getting rid of my
goals for a hundred days but when I
first set out to do I didn't like say
I'm going to get rid of my goals for a
hundred days because I didn't want to
make it a goal and so I'm just going to
try this for a while because these goals
are stressing me out they're not doing
it so if I achieve these goals I'm
supposed to be happy and I was like wait
a minute
why would I be happy one of the goals I
may have a million dollars in the bank
right have a million dollars I was
really far away from that goal because I
had said I made really good money but
spent even better money and so that goal
wasn't going well but then I talked to
myself a lot I wanted million dollars
because then I'll be happy
why because I could tell myself I could
be happy okay I just tell myself now and
then if I were to achieve that great
there's nothing wrong with money Ryan
and I sure aren't allergic to money but
it's not going to define my happiness
it's going to allow me to make either
better decisions with my life because
I'm already making good decisions or if
I'm making bad decisions it's going to
enable to me to make much worse
decisions it's why most lottery winners
end up broke and much worse position
than when they started
and so I love decided let go of my goals
and instead said how long have I to
start traveling in the direction I want
to travel not having a specific goal but
knowing where generally I'm going to go
that's going to give me the flexibility
I need so my short answer to you is let
go of your goals and instead travel in
the right direction
bottom of the ninth Nicodemus oh I'm
sure you're gonna win Josh um no you
know it's plenty maybe go back to my
friend who had the three things that
they that she really wanted to focus on
she wanted to be like an amazing poet
slash writer and an amazing artist and
actress and you know when I look at that
I you know I tried to like as she was
pushing back like I knew you'd say just
pick one thing I tried to push back and
I'm like well you don't have to just
like abandon everything else but you
know you have to focus at least on one
thing and I think about the goals I had
when I first started this whole journey
and I started one at a time I started
with getting rid of my car payment I
said and then I moved to getting rid of
my mortgage selling my house and I would
kind of move through these things one at
a time now if I would have put ten
things on my plate at once
like literally Josh like 2010 2009 he
came up with this amazing spreadsheet
this goals spreadsheet where it was
literally like 10 places for 10 goals
you pick your top 10 goals because
everyone has more than ten so you have
to pick your top right okay and then you
know there's like a different different
columns for things and concatenating to
formulas and different pages on this
thing and at first only here one person
giggle because they're like the Excel
person in the room right I'm like I'm
like you know this is this is awesome
like I can totally keep track of my
progress and in the next steps and you
know what I would I really need to do to
get these these goals reach and let me
tell you what happened with a
spreadsheet of ten goals nothing
happened
it was it was so watered down it was so
it was so overwhelming that yet maybe I
was like twenty percent to one forty
percent to another and thirty percent
let me tell you what twenty and thirty
and forty percent means when working
towards a goal it's really not that much
and that's all I had is I had a lot of
goals that were not not very not very
close to being reached so what I would
say I guess my short answer would be
don't water down your goals with more
goals but regardless of how many goals
you have it doesn't mean anything
without taking massive action beautiful
thank God thank you alright so I'm going
I am going to apologize to anyone else
who wants to ask a question that's
waiting I see a cluster of people I got
a beat of this okay where is this young
man that was sitting here that had a
question come here man there we go oh he
doesn't have to come up if he doesn't
want to
no worries alright he's tired
all right Josh close this out that's a
great question eight years old but this
is why this is why we do this like the
fact that an eight-year-old can show up
to the event and get something out of it
like that that means the world to me if
it was just him that got something out
of it like that before
so for the people lifting at home the
question was how does minimalism apply
to kids and we haven't we have an
eight-year-old here who's asking this
question Ryan you're a kid oh man
um I wish I was that smart when I was
eight to like think about minimalism
doing something from my life it wasn't
until I was 28 until I realized that
that might be a good good way to go I
guess um the tweetable answer would be
Josh no matter your age no matter your
race no matter your level of income
no matter your perceived status everyone
can benefit from living a more
meaningful life that's good yeah
[Music]
man maybe I'll just like concede on this
one yeah that was good man
uh I guess Ari this isn't nearly as
awesome as that answer but I I think I
would just say um if kids this is kind
of tongue-in-cheek so I'm just going to
preface it with that kids become
minimalist now before you have to in the
future
[Applause]
[Music]
Ryan Nicodemus at the wind plus he got a
bonus point for carrying me onto the
stage tonight I gotta apologize real
quick to the other folks who wanted to
ask questions I'd love to stay here all
night and talk to all of you but I know
eventually they would kick us out of
here and we need to move on to our added
value portion of the show this is where
Ryan and I talk about what's been adding
value to our lives recently and let's do
it with a local twist tonight Ryan what
has has been adding value to your life
and Madison Wisconsin oh man um I am
totally drawing a blank on the name of
this restaurant I just say that why
don't you why don't you tell your added
value and I'm going to look it up a book
deal there's a blue plate diner right
across the street that I ate out for
dinner
[Applause]
and they serve breakfast all day which
is always a win in my book
so to those of you at home we were
traveling through Madison Wisconsin you
can't go wrong with the sweet potato
frittata over at the blue paid to play
diner all right I found it um so there's
this like this restaurant like two doors
down that serves Lao food so Josh a
duplicate plate and I added a a mice and
this rail au LAN Xang restaurant okay
all right I heard someone say yeah I'm
gonna go with that valve and Zhang Lao a
little scent unbelievable I had I had
the the leg zucchini or no I'm sorry the
squash curry unbelievable oh no what's
up look at that and you know it's funny
it's like I ordered I ordered chicken
and I got back here and they gave me
tofu and I was like Oh tag on it like
they can I got my word wrong I was not
upset like it was so freaking amazing so
if you have any in there like it's it's
definitely good I was in I was in Laos a
couple years ago when when I was the
school that I had mentioned earlier we
built a school over in Laos and the food
the food's there um it was really really
good but like they they're not in Laos
I'm like it's even better over there so
so check it out all right well real
quick let's move on to right here right
now so we get to talk about what's going
on in the lives of the minimalists when
I'm done bleeding what Ryan and I are
going to do is we're actually in the
process right now of building a
podcasting and film studio we're trying
to do a lot more film stuff with our
podcast just with our message in general
the documentary that we put out last
year called minimalism it yeah someone
watched it ah
a few of you watched it that's great if
it really resonated with a lot of people
and it showed people that minimalism
wasn't a a radical lifestyle with the
practical lifestyle we want to do more
with video but that costs a lot of money
so we are in the middle of building that
that podcast a film studio it's going to
take quite a bit of capital to do that
so we are looking for some support
because it refused to clutter the
podcast with any advertisements
whatsoever and so if you'd like to
support us you can just go to the
minimalists comm and click on a little
donate button there we're doing
something called patreon so you can
donate on a per episode basis and that's
going to help us build that it's also
going to help us pay podcasts on a
full-time living wage for for doing the
podcast and by the way none of that
money goes to me or Ryan if there's any
additional funds left over oh we're
going to hire a full-time filmmaker as
well with those funds so if there's any
money left over it's going to go to
charity speaking of charity if you can't
afford to make any kind of contribution
to the podcast totally understand that
if you'd let still like to support us
you can just go over to Apple podcasts
and leave us a review this month which
is May 2017 for everyone who leaves a
review we're going to donate $10 to a
charity in your name now we picked the
special charity this month did you all
know that that man out of everyone who's
ever lived on planet earth half of those
people have died from malaria and we'd
like to help out a little bit with that
and so what we're doing is we're
donating 10 bucks for every review we
get this month which helps spread our
message it gets it in front of more
people more ears but it also allows to
do something cool with with this charity
as well so we're going to donate $10 to
the against malaria foundation they
estimate it costs about $3,500 to to
save one life so buy enough mosquito
nets and and treatments over the course
of a lifetime to save one life so if we
get 350 reviews which there's nearly
twice that here tonight you could save
you know about two lives
if you were all willing to hop on and
and leave a review and by the way if the
people at home left review we would save
a lot more lives so you're willing to
help out with that - tapan leave a quick
30 60 second review we would love five
stars but if you hate our guts because
someone dragged you here and you're like
I have whatever 1 star idiots that's
okay we'll still donate 10 bucks in your
name
we're really having a blast on the road
you know I'm grateful that I'm not
grateful this happened but for those of
you listening I'm pointing to my leg and
the bandage is on my leg right now and
the goofy flip-flop and this this pillow
that I'm sure is I'm catching something
from but I'm actually grateful that I
mean this could have been much worse and
I'll tell you this if I hadn't I lived a
life of Perpetual stress and anxiety and
discontent throughout my 20s and I was
all sensibly successful but but I I
would have not be able to handle this
very well and and yeah I mean there was
a level of panic in me because I thought
I was going to bleed out on the loves
bathroom floor but I certainly couldn't
have handled handled that and handled
the amount of pain that is I mean the
throbbing is going on right now is is
absurd if I hadn't simplified my life
because dealing with that external
clutter in my life has allowed me to
deal with the internal clutter the
mental clutter the emotional clutter the
the spiritual clutter of the financial
clutter the stuff that's going on inside
and ultimately I've become more aware of
what's going on inside me so I can be
aware of what's going on around me and
realizing that this could have been so
much worse this will hopefully he'll
eventually and and I'll be able to move
on with my life and I'm really grateful
that you all decided to to spend a few
hours with us tonight I know that it
cost some money to get in here and we're
grateful that you're willing to to give
up that resource but you gave up a
couple of really important resources in
addition to that you gave up your time
you gave up your attention and those are
two most precious resources and so for
the folks of you those you who are
listening at home if you're interested
in giving up a little bit of your time
and attention you can go to lessons
now.com or go into 40 different cities
all around all around the US and Canada
and then maybe we'll go elsewhere next
year as well overseas we just announced
the second leg of the tour as well so if
we're not coming to your city we're
coming to a city within a few hours
drive of
we'd love to see you out on the road
before I close it up I'd love to to
thank a few people I already think Jess
and and Shawn what about this venue for
accommodating us what about the Baroness
theater yeah I'm just really grateful
that awesome places like this are
willing to to let us sit on the stage
and bleed all over their couch cushions
but uh I'm really grateful for what Ryan
is about to do because this is this
actually pains me a little bit I
afterward we hang out for you know hour
or so we take a 20-minute break and then
we have an awesome plug line we sign
books we take photos and all that fun
stuff but I am in a hideous amount of
pain right now and so Ryan is going to
go out there solo and if you want me to
sign Josh's name I got his signature
down but that's our back-up plan I've
written several books out for after I
die there's it's gonna be like Tupac
they're just going to keep coming right
[Laughter]
now so so Ryan will be out there hugs
photos all that fun stuff and I owe you
a hug for next time so whether you come
to the Milwaukee stop in in December and
will embrace in the snow then or next
time we're in Madison I'm really
grateful you decided to be here and if
you leave here tonight with just one
message we hope it's this love people oh
by the way hold on hold on
my partner's here tonight and Rebecca is
a and Rebecca is a badger is that a W
you're holding up nice yeah they do the
two hands but those thoughts those no
all right I'm out of touch yeah I met
the love of my life a few years ago and
she was at school here lived here for
five years and she doesn't speak more
highly of any other place than Madison
Wisconsin so thank you for being here
thank you I love you all right now if
you leave here with one message we hope
with this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
your time you know thanks so much
Madison
[Applause]
hello my name is Sheila Morris I am
calling you from Edinburgh in Scotland
I'm calling you regarding a guest idea I
have children and my tween and their
twenties and this year for Christmas I
gave them an annual travel insurance I
know you need to know the people well to
be able your toughest but they were so
appreciative of a gift that lasts all
year round I mean that they do not need
to think about it is there and I will
renew it next Christmas Eve and time for
the policy on Christmas tea hey this is
Casey I just had a minimalist guest tip
or a sot i forget what you guys call it
basically basically there's my phone i
just play a little game with myself
let's say so Monday night I charge it up
wake up Tuesday it's a hundred percent
so I can't charge my phone until it dies
all the way or until obviously if it's
you know let's say Wednesday night and
it's at 5% I can charge it because it's
my alarm so I just thought that was a
cool game if your phone dies on you at
9:00 a.m. on a Tuesday then that's on
you and you got to go the rest of the
day without your phone so I just I
thought maybe some might like to try it
out and have some fun with it I wanted
to call in to share a recent revelation
that I had which has removed numerous
roadblocks I've come up against on my
quest for a more minimalist lifestyle
the public library I hadn't been to the
public library since about high school
and I can't believe I had forgotten all
of the free resources available at my
local library that previously I had been
routinely and wastefully paying for
movies and movie rentals magazines and
magazine subscriptions books many of
which if I decided to purchase and not
rent lingered around in my house
collecting dust until I got around to
minimizing them even the due date on the
materials I get from the library now is
helpful it motivates me to complete the
book or magazine in timely manner
allowing me to fit in more information
over time
which I enjoy since I tend to mosey
through those items if I own them my
interest often grows cold
I'm saving even by having a quiet well
lighted location with plenty of space
and outlets to do work something I had
actually been paying money for by
working in places like Starbucks or
Barnes & Noble where I felt pressured to
purchase a coffee or snack in exchange
for the work location I don't have those
pressures at the library which is good
for my wallet and my health
in fact I realized I was actually losing
money by not using the library since the
tax dollars that I necessarily pay were
going towards the upkeep of the library
which I was not utilizing I encourage
encourage all of us who are looking for
a more minimalist lifestyle but who
don't want to sacrifice the luxury of
indulging in printed or digital media in
a pleasant workspace outside of the home
to rediscover their public library and
other free offerings in their community
something that's simple and easy
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you thing that you me
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bet that you define
without it every little thing that you
gotta hang
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for you got a grand boy
there Thank You be fine without you so
tear your eyes
[Music]